the Joe Rogan experience you ever do be
real smoke box be very good yeah I've
been that's too hectic please be careful
cuz you got a drive home after that and
you don't even know where you are if it
wasn't for navigation systems I'd still
be living in downtown LA yeah I would
have never figured out how to get home
that's what the test that comes in for
drive for you yeah it's like these guys
just smoke all day every day and to them
that's their baseline like their normal
is just being SuperDuper high so they're
they're used to it like that we we got
so high before we even got into the car
you know and then you get into the car
with the cameras in it and then they do
like this podcast and you like it's
surreal it's like an out-of-body
experience yeah and you feel really
paranoid and really worked up like long
yeah no thanks I don't like that [ __ ] I
don't like that why why why even bother
doing that no one likes that they do
obviously somebody likes that how
there's people that like that
yeah they put their like the leaf
blowers full of weed and just blow it on
each other it's tons of videos like High
Times conventions and yeah cannabis cups
cuz they take a leaf blower and they
pump a bong up yeah it's ridiculous I
mean but this is like these are the
arguments for weed being illegal it's
like look at these idiots it's awesome
but chugging but but chug chug yeah but
the thing is like it's weird it's like
we have this line of personal
responsibility right you can go to any
bar and they don't check to see if
you've already been drinking they don't
know what your tolerance is they don't
anything you get any bar give me two
shots of Jack Daniels and a Grey Goose
on the rocks there just give it to you
bang nobody cares
they just think you could figure it out
you know how much of a responsibility as
a bartender actually had a lot who then
yeah they can go they can go to jail to
the bartender can if they don't
negotiate I think yeah that to me is so
ridiculous I don't think the but I think
over-serve like if you get over-served
and they can prove it you're just as
responsible if he can't he like drives
home drunk didn't kill somebody do you
well if you know someone's gonna drive
this the problem is like I was talking
about this on stage once
the real problem with drunk driving is
not that people can't drive when they're
drunk the problem when you're drinking
is you don't know if you can drive or
not you don't know how drunk you are
because you're drunk like you might have
three drinks and you might fail a drunk
driving breathalyzer but you might be
able to drive perfectly you know but if
you have four drinks or five drinks you
might think it's okay to have six or
seven like you don't know where you are
you don't know like where you are on the
spectrum of drunk or not drunk when
you're really drunk
that's part of being drugged you know
the [ __ ] going on that's why I like
that's why the consent issue when you're
really drunk is weird you know it's
cause it's like some people like to get
drunk and have sex and then some people
say well you should never have sex with
someone when they're drunk
because they can't consent because
they're drunk okay
but then that's like 90% of all people
having sex yeah how many people have sex
while they're drunk I only have well I
think autonomous cars it's gonna that's
gonna be very interesting how they deal
with alcohol and autonomous cars because
if like you have a drunk mode like if
autonomous car like say if you have a
Tesla in 2026 right and it has the
option to be completely autonomous it
drives on its own or you can go manual
so it detects that you're drunk says mr.
Redmayne you are intoxicated we would
like to drive and then you have to let
it take you like would you get do you
think there's gonna be a component time
where drunk driving doesn't apply
because your car is gonna drive you home
it makes the final decision for you I'm
all for it like just it wouldn't be hard
to have a breathalyzer on a car did do
that now yeah I have a friend who he he
got arrested for a DUI like more than
one and he had to blow in his thing on
his van as work van hit a blow into his
little thing before I would let
start the car this is another demolition
man coming full circle again because
there's that scene where he gets in and
he makes the car he's like give me give
me control and she's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing you're gonna drive he's
like yeah manual control give me that
[ __ ] need the chases after what year was
demolition man's place bein now I think
I'll double-check I might need to watch
that again it was nuts they're doing
that THC a breathalyzer next year what
are they gonna find out supposedly it
detects if there's THC like if you have
smoked in the last whatever three
problem with that is there's I don't
they've done studies that show that
people drive well when they're high you
know they have done studies there's been
these tests and they're not you know
it's not randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled studies but they are
they have done some studies when they
show that people drive well hi I know
they have twenty or thirty two is not
far away
that's actually pretty close it gets
frozen for 36 years and wakes up in 2032
oh wow is that funny what they used to
think is gonna be going on you know like
yeah mm they'll just be able to freeze
you what wasn't that back to their
future that was like 2017 or something
like that after - yeah and then you look
at you're like that's yeah when when
they came but well yeah the second one
back to future -
[Applause]